you know we we talked a bit about uh
uh giving out checks to people the
government's inability to do things
well we've got another big story that i
think plays into the government's
abilities to do
ability to do things that actually what
you guys are saying makes me a little
bit more confident because we have the
story cbs news reports biden calls on
congress to ban assault weapons
and institute other gun restrictions
suppose the good news there is that as
we just mentioned they can't get
giving up money right they can't even
give people money
are they going to be able to actually
implement that yeah how are they going
to actually be able to take anybody's
guns away or do anything like that
they seem to have no idea what they're
doing the thing is it won't and it will
create more conflict and it will create
more fights and it will create a really
nasty
situation inside of the united states
and it seems like some people
within our government are hell-bent at
fighting each other and i think this is
exactly what
this particular bigger grab of authority
away from the people is
you're pretty much saying that you're
not you're not saying that guns are bad
you're just saying that
only the special privileged people
should have guns the politicians should
have guns in i don't know why we're not
making this more of a talking point
but gun control specifically united in
the united states is based off
institutional racism and white supremacy
there's a long history of that but but
hold on and you would i think that's
that's not even like some haha got you
talking about
not this is actually something the left
does say
all the time because people need to
understand leftists and liberals are not
the same
thing it's the liberal corporate
democrat types establishment types that
are like ban all the guns
leftists like antifa they're like nah we
like our guns
they're pro 2a they're tools of the
revolution they love that stuff
yeah i mean i'm a little i guess i'm a
little more optimistic on the front of
what's going to happen because i think
the courts are going to shut that down
um you know much of the early assault
weapons
ban stuff that predates dc versus heller
and the big cases that the supreme court
ruled on which basically
protects the individual right to guns
that are in common use and i think that
there might be no more
gun that's more in common use than the
ar15 it's the most commonly purchased
well so
first let me just say the the gist of
the story is if i didn't put out this
campaign statement
saying we need to ban assault weapons
universal background checks
what you need to understand about
assault weapons is there have been
there's no definition
yeah assault weapon is meaningless
assault
rifle typically refers to select fire a
selective fire rifle so they can do
single burst and full auto
those have been illegal even before they
were invented because of
i guess like was it nfa was that it i
don't i'm not the smart like the most
gun person ever
i can already see all the chat lighting
up with people saying there's no idea
right the point is assault rifles
are not legal they can do full auto
assault weapon has no unifying
definition
and it makes literally no sense in some
states like there's like a standard
there's like uh uh in some states for
instance the m1 is illegal
and like for what reason is that illegal
and then your standard like
uh scar or whatever is legal it's like
cosmetic
differences but i mean something on
assault weapon versus not totally not
related to function
it's it's it's no it's like well that
weapon was once used in war so it's
illegal but the other one that's more
modern more powerful and more efficient
is totally fine
it's meaningless so i i suppose
the the bigger picture is whether or not
the government will be able to
do it and you mentioned you're a bit
more optimistic on the court shutting
this down
but my my question is it's uh the second
amendment
what is it what do you know the text of
the second amendment will uh
you know the rights of let's let i'm
trying not off the top of that you don't
need to give it verbatim but yeah like
something because like the a well-armed
or well-regulated militia being
necessary to the health of a free
society the right to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed what's that last
part
it shall not be infringed before that
the right to keep and bear arms
those two words what were they keep keep
and bear bear means
and that's part of the heller decision
right like the ability to
so i think a later one so why is it that
in dc for instance i can't legally bear
arms
um because courts i mean
the way these amendments are interpreted
they're you know judicial interpretation
judicial gloss changes things i mean so
manipulation and power
are people the politicians in dc are
like i'll be damned if i'm gonna let
anyone challenge me
pre-heller i mean you know before heller
was ruled the ninth circuit
had already decided that the ability to
keep and
you know keep a handgun in your home was
not part of the second amendment
yeah right it took heller to reverse
then be like no there's an individual
right to bear arms in your home
and that's and you know why that's
absolutely insane yeah the initial
language of the second amendment before
it was called the second amendment it
was called like article five or
something i can't remember which article
it
was
there were 17 articles proposed for the
constitution and the first two
had to do with like congress and
apportionment or something like that but
the original text literally said
basically even if somebody doesn't want
to be in a militia they're allowed to
have a gun
and they took that out i guess i was
reading they were worried it would
outlaw conscription
and considering it was you know the
birth of a new nation they're like we
need to be able to force people to fight
wars for us
you know and look i'm not trying to be a
dick like back then we had the war of
1812 you know we had the british
kidnapping people we were weak right
people forget how weak
we were like britain won the war of 1812
and then made a nice piece with us
because they were more worried about
napoleon
but you know you know i love i i was
reading right i was reading about it how
it's one of the few wars where everyone
declared victory and the only loser was
the was the native americans who were
caught in the crossfire
i mean you know madison sent our troops
up into like canada and then
britain showed up oh look you left your
capital unoccupied i guess we'll burn it
to the ground yeah i remember that
like and i mean we were we were losing
badly
because they were a massive naval power
we were very very weak
and again i mean again the only reason
they just they just got annoyed by it
they're like okay napoleon's conquering
all of europe right now that's a little
more important
than what those colonies are doing yeah
we almost we almost took uh
montreal the u.s tried to take montreal
and you know and so it's entirely
possible that would have been america
but
so the initial uh proposal for the
second amendment
actually was longer and it basically
said in the event even somebody does not
want to join a militia they can still
have that weapon they took it out
and then that leaves us today where you
have these people who are arguing like
it says a well-regulated militia first
of all which definition
which definition of regulated are they
saying regulated in the term in in the
sense of
armed and efficient like well-regulated
in the sense that everyone's got a
weapon
or regulated in the sense that the
government controls what they do it's a
modern interpretation
off of what they may have it's also just
bad grammar right like the
the first like people should uh know how
to read an english sentence
the first phrase a prefatory phrase is
like
here is one reason why we're going to
enact this rule
right a well-regulated militia being
necessary to health of a free state
it's like that's one reason we're or the
reason that we're going to do this
and then we say the rule the right of
the people to keep them bear arms shall
not be infringed
so that's that's the big issue joe biden
says he wants to do this
we've got uh we got the story from
michigan live how riots politics and a
pandemic drove record gun sales in
michigan from february 13th but
this is just one story i just pulled up
i mean we've had record sales record
background checks for the past
year because the riots the pandemic and
politics
so now now we're hearing from joe biden
he wants to start banning assault
weapons
but by their definition that's like in
some this is the craziest thing you
somewhat one weapon you can buy in say
you know new york
you can't even bring to new jersey you
could live in philadelphia
literally on the water you cross over
the other side with a totally legal
weapon not an assault weapon
definition change is outright so the
first thing i have to i suppose they'd
have to do is define what an assault
weapon was
i'll tell you the scary thing is there
was an attempt several years ago to
define
any semi-automatic weapon as an assault
weapon which meant
literally the handgun a cop uses so i
went down to
march for our lives this big the big
protests i think in 2017 or 18
and i was asking people and i wasn't
trying to do this gotcha stuff that you
often see on youtube where they're like
you're so dumb explain it you know like
jimmy kimmel does or whatever i saw
people holding signs saying ban assault
rifles
and so i would ask them like are you
aware that they're already banned and
then they would go oh and they would
like pull their sign down and fold it up
and then hide it like i guess you didn't
realize i
wasn't trying to get you and then i
would ask some people very simply i had
the bill pulled up that was proposed
that would make like a glock 17 illegal
as an assault weapon
it would literally define the handgun as
an assault weapon one of the most common
weapons in the country
and so i would ask people do you think
assault weapons should be banned yes
do you think that includes say
semi-automatic handguns and they'll go
no of course not
what about like you know a glock 17 or
something like a cop would use or a
glock 19
and they would be like no no no that's
that we just mean high-powered
rifles where you can get off like 30
rounds in a few minutes
and then i would show them the bill you
know from like gov track and i'd be like
here's the current bill do you agree
with what the democrats are proposing
and they'll go oh no no i absolutely do
not agree with that
and i'll be like i mean maybe it's
important that you know all these
millions of people coming out here
know that i mean you you'd come out here
and a lot of people were shocked
they didn't realize just how serious it
was that there have been proposals even
to get rid of
semi-automatic you see i don't know if
you guys remember that uh
was it cnn or whatever where they they
said fully semi-automatic what
right yeah like they don't even know
what they're talking about
and so there's a lot of people who think
semi-automatic means you hold the
trigger down you know
full auto it's not it's it's it's
remarkable how
uh so i recently i i guess you're not
supposed to say what kind of weapons you
have
but look it's probably fine if i mention
this one i just got right you think it's
i don't know
what the the big one no no no no no
well no the hunting one okay so i got a
i got a bolt action
450 bushmaster ruger and uh when i was
buying it
they were just basically saying to me
like you should have no problems with
this bolt action it's great
it's excellent for hunting you know it
was designed for for you know for for
deer and stuff like that
and i was like oh that's perfect in the
event we do want to go hunting or
something like that and we want to go
out with somebody
and then i asked them i was like why is
it that they regulate the the
you know the ar-15s but this thing is
like just not even on the books and
they're you know well because they don't
do
what they're talking about and i had
several people tell me that less moving
parts
on the the the bolt action uh the bolt
action 450 these are these are you know
decently large rounds
they're more accurate at longer
distances they're potentially more
dangerous from somebody who wants to
cause harm
but because these politicians have no
idea what they're talking about they
think the scary black looking rifle
is a military weapon it's got to be
banned meanwhile this hunting rifle
which is actually more deadly and more
accurate
they're like oh that's fine that's
that's what well you know what i think
the better way to put it is i can talk
all about this stuff as i'm discovering
it and exploring it as i go to the gun
shop and i'm buying these things and a
lot of the people who own guns are
sitting there laughing banging like ah
he's
they're laughing like ah young tim
finally learning what it's like
but here's the funny thing about it it's
also a wake-up call to
it's it's kind of like the gel man
amnesia effect for those that aren't
familiar
the idea of the galman amnesia effect is
when you read a news article about
something you're familiar with
so let's say you're a a gun owner and
you read a story saying assault weapons
will be banned
and then they make reference to things
that don't exist they they
get assault weapon wrong and they define
words you laugh like these journalists
have no idea they say fully
semi-automatic they're so dumb
you turn the page and then it's like
conflict in syria 50 dead and you go wow
i didn't know that
the idea is you all of a sudden forgot
how incompetent these journalists were
i suppose there's another effect i would
like in this too is
people believe in government until they
realize there's an area of government
they're familiar with
and how awful it's being controlled and
regulated so as soon as you start
getting into like buying guns and going
to class which a lot of people are doing
all of a sudden you go if they're doing
this really bad
what other regulations do we have that
are just as bad
if they don't know what an assault
weapon is and can't define it
how are they handling medicine so this
is super funny to me because the lady
who sold me my
personal weapon of choice um in a
different state was like well the state
that you live in does not like this gun
because it looks
scary and that kind of struck me as
strange because i was like the people
who are
actually regulating the things that we
can and can't buy this literal right
that we have that's in the constitution
they have no idea what they're talking
about they know nothing about what
they're saying
and they think that they have a right to
like tell us what we can and can't do
it's in the constitution i'm sorry you
may not like it well
another thing to really consider here is
is this this is a very unpopular move by
biden
people have been buying guns in record
numbers even in big cities
even a lot of people on the left yeah a
lot of people on the left have been
buying firearms and i i truly believe
this is
done in an effort to push for more chaos
order out of chaos is usually the big
kind of agenda that you see from a lot
of these politicians that try to stir up
a whole bunch of problems and then come
in with the larger solution
at all costs we need to prevent violence
from happening
and uh the people in brazil are having
the opposite problem as i'm learning
right now
i'm reading an article that's talking
about how bolsonaro
in brazil is trying to make it easier
for
citizens to get guns more easily
and uh the guardian has a propaganda
article about this and it's titled anger
as bolsonaro moves to make guns easier
to access
a threat to democracy people need to
understand
when you're armed with a firearm this is
what politicians are protected by so if
the politicians could have protections
why can't the average citizen
be able to protect themselves and their
properties when it comes to criminals
like in mexico or let's say chicago
places where guns are illegal
criminals still magically get guns and
firearms thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you